مرحبا في ثالث التعاون ما بينهم علقت مير
هالحسين علاء دورها هكذا زوجه ثانيه في
مسلسل الوينج مع محمد رجب بانه مختلفه عن
كل شيء سبقوه وان ليست متخوفه من ردود
الفعل حتى وان كان الدور مستفز الا انها
على قناعه تامه بن الجمهور وبعد المشاهده
راح يغير رايه تماما مسلسل الونش تعريف
احمد عبد الفتاح واخراج اسماعيل فاروق
بطوله محمد رجب محمود عبد المغني مريهان
حسين من نفضى عليه وغيرهم تتجسد مرهون
خلال الاحداث دور بنت فقيره بتعمل بائعه
في الملابس يتعرف عليها محمد رجب وتبدا
بعينهم حكايه
انا بعمل نواره شخصيه جديده عليا جدا
احبها جدا
ويا رب الناس يحبوها على قد حبي وتعبي
فيها حبايه رغم ان هي زوجه ثانيه
يعني هي جزء من حدوته في حدوته بنقدمها
للناس نواره شخصيه فيها
[موسيقى]
عبره الفنانه انوشكا والقدمه العام الماضي
واحد من المع ادوارها في مسلسل راجعين يا
هوا مع خالد النبوي عن رغبتها الشديده في
العوده للسينما ولغناء ايضا كونها ابتعدت
على الموسيقى من فتره طويله رغم انها بدات
كم مغنيه لكن التمثيل اخدها من ذلك
المشكله لم تبدا فقط كم مغني يابا ايضا
كاس استعراضيه لكنها كانت مقله وبالتدريج
حتى توقفت الصالح التمثيل وبسبب انشغال
لها في واكدت لكواليس انه هذه الرغبه
خلتها غير قادره حتى الان على حسب موقفها
من رمضان القادم وما اذا كانت راحتي واقعه
على مسلسل جديد رغم انها في مرحله القراءه
حاليا انا علشان زي ما باقول دائما همم
السنوات بتجري وعلشان نحضر رمضان شغل
رمضان بنصور ب 16 17 ساعه في اليوم ده بلا
مبالغه علشان نلحق همم
المسلسلات يا رمضان
ما باقدرش اوافق ما بين الاثنين وده خطا
مني انا
الفتره اللي جايه اا انا عن نفسي المسرح
واحشني جدا وقفه الخشبه المسرح ومواجهه
الجمهور همم وحشاني جدا
اهتمام كبير احد بندوره السينما السعوديه
في مهرجان القاهره السينمائي واللي شارك
فيها عده سينمائيين في مقدمتهم رئيسه مجلس
اداره جمعيه السينما المخرجه ناد عمير
ونائب رئيس هيئه الافلام السعوديه الاستاذ
عبد الجليل الناصر بينما كان ظهور الابرز
في الندوه لمخرج الفيلم السعودي المرشح
لتمثيل السعوديه في حفل الاوسكار القادمه
افضل في فيلم اجنبي وهو المخرج محمد
السلمان بالفيلمو اغنيه الغرام
في وجود السينما السعوديه همم
مستقره وهل ردي احنا قطعنا شاطئ هذا
واتوقع ان العام الجاي راح يكون في رقم
جديد من عدد الافلام الطويله اللي راح
تعرض في السينما
تحدث الفنان احمد خالد صالح لكواليس عن
اسباب مشاركته في فيلم 19 للمخرج احمد عبد
الله اللي لاقى اعجاب نقدي كبير في مهرجان
القاهره السينمائي الدولي بسبب موضوع
الرمزيه في الفيلم والمقصود منه صناعه
فيلم يدعوك للتفكير بعمق ومحاوله الخروج
باجابات بمعنى انه التفكير في الفيلم غني
وثري كما وصفته الصحابه
لان معروف في اسماء معينه
تشتركوش في اي مشروع او ما بيعملوش اي
مشروع لان هو وراءه هدف حقيقي وقرار رساله
حقيقيه فيلم الانساني يعني ما اقدرش اقول
ان هو في جانيرو معينه او تحت مسمى معين
اهو فيلم ثاني عن شخصين هتشوفهم يعني مجرد
ما هتشوفهم هتحس انك هتشوفهم قبل كده في
حياتها
بشراكم نتوقف الان مع جديد بعض النجوم ما
بين الدراما والسينما واشياء اخرى
عملتها
في شهر ديسمبر فيلم السر
في مجموعه كبيره من نجوم احمد السقا ياسر
ياسين شريف منير كان لسه معك
محمد ممدوح فيلم قوي مسلسل حلقه
بيحصل كتير
بطوله الجميل
هنيدي
وخالد مرعي المخرج الكبير ونور البطله
واسماء ما شاء الله ابطال يعني نمت عندي
ان شاء الله مسلسلات رمضان وعندي الفيلم
وهو هو سايكو دراما الفيلم اسمه شمس اييه
المسلسلات لسه يعني ما اقدرش اقول دلوقتي
اسامي اا بس
فيلم بقى هو بيصنف سيكو دراما
بيحكي عن قصه شويه